this is one of the tactics that Donald
Trump uses to back up a lot of his
claims some people would say don't do
that a lot of people are very skeptical
a lot of people said I want one of those
people is Alex Jones so who exactly is
Alex Jones I'm a human and uncommon he's
a conspiracy theorist but I've been told
this by high up folks they said listen
Obama and Hillary both smell like sulfur
he's let's call it emotional and he has
a huge following and now with Donald
Trump's blessing I just want to finish
by saying your reputation is amazing I
will not let you down he's in the
spotlight this is the story about how
Alex Jones was plucked from the niche
corners of the internet reserved for
conspiracy theorists and thrust onstage
into the national spotlight Alex Jones
is born in Dallas Texas in 1974 where he
had a self-described all-american life
his father was a dentist his mom
homemaker who was in high school when he
became a conspiracy theorist like a lot
of teenagers he's got a book called none
dare call it conspiracy which was the
book that politicized him that's the
author Jon Ronson back in the 90s I
wrote a book called Levin which kind of
gave the world Alex Jones
Alex honed his voice as the libertarian
conspiracy theorist at community access
radio in Austin it's also where Austin
filmmaker Richard Linklater noticed I'm
casting Jones in his 2001 film waking
life
Jones is also a big 9/11 truther and he
was one of the first people to say 9/11
was an inside job we're gonna be talking
about the attack last Tuesday on the
World Trade Center being a federal
operation resulted in dozens of radio
stations across America to drop his show
but Jones didn't let that stop and for
the next 15 years he continued his
conspiracy crusade calling stories like
the San Bernardino shooting the Sandy
Hook massacre and even the Apollo moon
landing flags
he spun those theories and many others
into a miniature media empire as Alex
Jones shows now broadcasts on more than
100 radio stations nationwide a show
that he's simulcast on his YouTube
channel which has nearly 2 million
subscribers and his web site info
wars.com gets anywhere from one to four
million unique users every month
according to comScore even with those
numbers online Alex Jones his show and
his opinions were far from mainstream
until Donald Trump exposed them to a
much wider audience America thank you so
much the president has Alex Jones then
there was this a few days ago I called
the fake news the enemy of the people
and they are getting your head around
the fact that the mainstream media is
the enemy the enemy of the American
people on Twitter Jones took credit for
coining the phrase in 2015
Trump has retweeted senior Infowars
editor Paul Joseph Watson who goes
by prison planet and tweeted out an
Infowars link as well neither Jones nor
the White House responded to requests
for comment
overall Ronson says that Alex Jones has
played his card supporting Donald Trump
perfect so he may be loud and he may
have some wild ideas but as long as he's
hitching his wagon to Donald Trump Alex
Jones will continue to remain in the
spotlight in American media
[Music]